any time when you're not sure and
there's a huge variance in outcome
equity is a great way to align
incentives and invest right if you know
what the outcome's going to be to your
point right you're going to be a doctor
it's going to be this to this that's
actually usually much cheaper right
that's not a great way you don't want to
finance a business with equity if you
know exactly what the curve is going to
be you finance a business with equity
when you don't
and the reality is that's that is where
the world is largely going i mean if you
look at the future
people's predictability on their income
and their careers it's not going up it's
going down and there's more there's more
random extreme outcomes which i actually
think means broadly speaking
the more we can align humanity around
equity-based financing rather than debt
right for the coming years the better
off would will generally be although we
are obviously starting to just be
creators yeah people going into debt
are not going to be able to take risk
people being invested in are going to
have capital to take more risks so when
you once you've got 200 000 in
your graduate degree or undergraduate
degree got forbid in debt you're
basically paying a mortgage out of
school which means how are you going to
start a company you're screwed from day
one 100
yeah and this was actually the thing you
know hilariously i've been trying to get
this done for like 20 years right like i
wrote my college entrance exam uh essays
partially on this because i was trying
to kind of come really 20 years ago
called life capital and this was exactly
the thesis then which is you know i grew
up in a privileged household which was
amazing and you think about what that
actually did for me the number one thing
it did for me is allow me to be risk
neutral right i didn't have to take the
safe path because i knew i would be well
fed and cared for no matter what and i
think the more as a society you can talk
about ubi right you can talk about a lot
of different things if we can neutralize
people's risk curves right i think in an
entrepreneurial technological age we'll
see way better stuff come from people
right right because they don't have to
you know do the thing that's just safe
to pay a mortgage committing to security
and compliance is vital for startup
growth and proof of security has never
been more important as you scale you
might start to receive more sock to
requests from customers of course and
that's where drada comes in trada is a
compliance automation platform used by
some of the world's leading csos cisos
you may have heard of it chief
information security officers a lot of
early state startups don't have a ciso
despite the obvious importance of
security and compliance with drata you
can easily meet requirements support
enterprise deal flow and track
compliance strata helps customers
prepare for and clear sock 2 and other
audits go from zero to audit ready in a
matter of weeks take it from philip
martin chief security officer at
coinbase he called drata solution well
ahead of other market players and said
drata provides users with the most
advanced automation available so here's
your cta check out drato's 5 star
reviews on g2 and see why companies like
clearco and smartrecruiter work with
drata for their compliance needs twist
listeners can get 15 off and waived
implementation fees at drata.com
twist
dot com drata.com twist